Aya-chan, I bought some snacks!
Yay!
Let's eat together!
What did you buy?
Chocolate mint ice!
And chocolate mint ice!
Mint, right?
Chocolate mint ice!
Breakfast and chocolate mint Lunch and dessert Added to dinner Eating every day makes me happy It's delicious but strange Why don't I eat it?
This overflowing face The cuteness I'll teach you With a blue and refreshing scent It leads to happiness Because it's a god's snack Sign of the call A happy world that only I can understand Ah, that's right To practice chocolate mint To study I wonder if I can form a student Mint-chan?
Chocolate mint ice ice ice It's cold Chocolate mint ice ice ice It's delicious Chocolate mint ice ice ice I'll fill you with love and dreams Chocolate mint ice ice ice One more Chocolate mint ice ice ice How is it?
Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice Chocolate mint ice ice ice ice
Thank you for watching this video.
Please subscribe to this channel and give it a high rating.
Thank you
for watching this video.
Please subscribe to this channel and give it a high rating.
Thank you for watching this video.
Bye -bye!